WELCOME TO.
COMMITTEE WE ARE.
READY TO GO.
I'D LIKE TO ANNOUNCE MY MISTER
FRAZIER WILL NOT BE HERE TODAY
MISS CERVANTES IS ON HER WAY
WILL BE TAKING HIS PLACE AND
THAT WE ARE PULLING. AB IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN OFF
TODAY.
BUT ALSO TAKING.
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY THREE
EGGMAN OFF CONSENT SO I'LL BE
PRESENTING THAT BILL MYSELF.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EGGMAN HERE EGGMAN PRESIDENT.
PATTERSON.
BURKE.
SAID ABOUT THIS.
LACKEY. LACKEY PRESENT MEDINA.
MEDINA PRESENT KIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA PRESENT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND FIRST UP WE
HAVE MISSED LIMON.
PRESENTING AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
TWO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO.
THAT IS THE STATE GRANTS
ADMINISTRATOR AT.
CA BILL I WANTED TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THINKING THE
CHAIRING COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING ON THE SPELL. NONPROFITS
RANKED AS THE FOURTH LARGEST
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA EMPLOYING
NEARLY ONE MILLION PEOPLE AND
PRODUCING MORE JOBS THAN
CONSTRUCTION FINANCE AND REAL
ESTATE INDUSTRIES.
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL GRANTS
MAKE UP HALF OF THE NONPROFIT
REVENUE MAKING THIS FUNDING
SOURCE CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS
OF THE INDUSTRY IT IS ALSO AN
INDUSTRY THAT WORKS VERY CLOSELY
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY DOES NOT
HAVE A CENTRALIZED DATABASE THAT
NONPROFITS CAN ACCESS TO
IDENTIFY STATE GRANTS THEY MIGHT
BE ELIGIBLE FOR MAKING IT
DIFFICULT FOR MANY NONPROFITS TO
FIND THE INFORMATION THEY NEED
ABOUT STATE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES. THIS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
UNDERSERVED AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES MAKING IT HARDER FOR
THEM TO COMPETE.
FOR AND PURSUE
HERE STATE FUNDS
BY MAKING CALIFORNIA GRANTS
ACCESSIBLE AND TRANSPARENT WE
CAN ENSURE ALL INTERESTED
ENTITIES HAVE A FAIR SHOT AT
STATE FUNDING. WITH ME TODAY
HAVE JENNIFER FEARING
REPRESENTING THE COW NONPROFITS
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THINK YOU'RE MUCH MISSED DURING
THE MORNING THAT I'M SHARON
MEMBERS JENNIFER HEARING ON
BEHALF OF COUNT ON PROFITS AND
ARE I'M STATEWIDE POLICY
ALLIANCE OF MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND ORGANIZATIONS AND. I
WILL NOT REPEAT THE EXTENT
ARGUMENTS MEAN I'M MADE BY THE
AUTHOR BUT I'LL JUST NOTE THAT
WE'VE ALREADY BEGUN VERY
POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THIS BILLS
OBJECTIVES AND WE'RE OPTIMISTIC.
ABOUT ITS PROSPECTS FOR CREATING
NEW AND INNOVATIVE WAYS FOR OUR
STATES NONPROFITS TO HELP THE
FILL THE STATE'S OBJECTIVES AND
WE ARE DRIVE OF.
WONDERFUL MANY OVEN SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT TODAY. ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS LOVELY BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OR
COMMITTEE APPROVAL IS BEEN
MOVED.
SECOND US OPEN IT I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT
AND FOR SOMEONE WHO ALSO
REPRESENTS AN AREA THAT IS OFTEN
UNDERSERVED THIS ABILITY TO HAVE
THE GRANTS WILL PEOPLE CAN SEE
THEM GOING ON IN TWO QUICK WEB
SEARCHES. TO FIND THINGS THAT
THEY CAN APPLY FOR A LOT OF
MONEY OUT THERE WE KNOW IT
DISPROPORTIONATELY GOES TO
HIGHER INCOME AREAS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE PROFESSIONAL GRANT WRITERS
AND PEOPLE TO CALL THROUGH AND
FIND THE GRANT SO. I THINK THIS
IS THAT THAT BRIDGE THAT WE NEED
TO DO TO OUR COMMUNITIES ANNA
AND THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING AT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT I THINK THIS
MAKES IT MORE MUCH MORE
STREAMLINED. A FOR ALL PARTS OF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REAR FOR TO THE COMMITTEE
AND APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT MONTH EGGMAN BY THAT AMOUNT
IS EGGMAN AYE PATTERSON.
BURKE.
SAID ABUNDANCE.
LACKEY A LACKEY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT AND WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OTHER PEOPLE
THAT I THINK VERY MUCH THE WORK.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
MISTER OBERNOLTE HAS ONE BILL ON
CONSENT I'M ASSUMING HE'S NOT
GONNA PRESENT.
THANK YOU A RIGHT AND THE OTHER
BILL IS AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
SEVEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE STATE
CONTRACT ACTS REQUIRES THAT ALL
CONTRACTS FOR VALUES OF OVER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS BE
PUT OUT TO BID AND THAT THE
CONTRACT BE AWARDED. TO THE
LOWEST RESPONSIVE BIDDER.
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE STATE THAT
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSIGHT OF
THAT ACT IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ARE TGS.
LOCAL AGENCIES MAY APPLY TO
DIGEST FOR EXEMPTIONS FROM THAT
REQUIREMENT IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES AND FOR GOOD
CAUSE.
LAST YEAR THE STATE AUDITOR
ISSUED A REPORT. THAT.
INVESTIGATED THE CIRCUMSTANCES
UNDER WHICH TGS HAD BEEN
GRANTING THOSE REQUESTS AND THE
REPORT FOUND THAT THE GS COULD
BE DOING A BETTER JOB
ADMINISTERING THAT PROGRAM. AND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD BE
DOING A GOOD JOB OF LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OF THOSE REQUESTS AND
THE AUDITOR. ISSUED SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS THIS BILL AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN
IMPLEMENTS THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
IT REQUIRES TGS TO CREATE AN
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
OF ALL REQUESTS FOR EXEMPTIONS
TO THAT REQUIREMENT OF BIDS OVER
VALUED OVER ONE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THAT THAT BE DONE ANNUALLY
THIS WILL RESULT IN.
BETTER OVERSIGHT OF THE PROGRAM
AND HOPEFULLY.
BETTER LEGISLATIVE.
VIEWPOINT AND WHAT'S GOING ON
OVER THERE AT WITH ALL
CONTRACTING PROCESS I BELIEVE
IT'S WORTHY OF YOUR SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE BILL
TODAY THEM OKAY ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL TODAY.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM.
THAT BILLS REMOVED SECOND IT.
I THINK IS A FINE COMMONSENSE
BILL MACHINE OBERNOLTE AND AND I
WILL ALSO BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TO A QUESTION FROM IS QUIRK
SILVA
ALLEGING THAT THERE'S FRAUD OR
ABUSE THERE BUT.
WHAT THE AUDITOR IS SAYING IS
THAT? I WE COULD DO A BETTER JOB
AT MAKING SURE THAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH THOSE
EXEMPTIONS ARE AWARDED ARE
APPROPRIATE.
OTHERS ARE VERY LIMITED CATEGORY
OF.
CASES IN WHICH A GOVERNMENT
AGENCY MAY MAY APPLY FOR AN
EXEMPTION WOULD FOR EXAMPLE OF
MEN EMERGENCY CONTRACT TO BE LET
YOU KNOW WHEN TIME IS CRITICAL.
OF CONTRACTS FOR LEGAL SERVICES
THINGS LIKE THAT BUT DOES THOSE
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE EXEMPTIONS
THAT ARE NOT THINGS ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE APPROVED REGULARLY I THINK
THAT WAS THE AUDITOR'S.
THE AUDITOR'S FEAR AND.
THAT'S WHAT THE AUDITOR OPINED
THAT WE COULD DO A BETTER JOB
OVERSEEING THAT AND.
WAS FELT THAT IT ANNUAL REPORT
TO JUST HIGHLIGHTED THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH THOSE
REQUESTS WERE BEING GRANTED WILL
BE HELPFUL.
A REAL QUICK COMMENT I THINK
IT'S HUMAN NATURE AND I THINK
IT'S NO DIFFERENT THE BUSINESS
WORLD THAT WHEN. PEOPLE ARE
WATCHING WE SENT PERFORMERS ARE
BEST.
AND SO THAT'S WHY I'M THANKFUL
FOR THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT
ENCOURAGES TO BE AT OUR BEST.
IF YOU SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
WHICH I TO CLOSE ON A MAP.
PLEASE CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND REAR
FOR TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TH ELEMENT THAT'S
EGGMAN BY SOME OF THIS EGGMAN
AYE AYE PATTERSON.
BURKE.
SAID A MONTH THIS
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE MEDINA MEDINA ICRC
SELA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
OBERNOLTE TWO BILLS OUT TODAY.
I SEE MR GARCIA SITTING HERE.
ONE USERS.
WELCOME.
JERRY.
COLLEAGUES REPRESENT YOU AB
TWENTY ONE OH SIX.
THE BILL THAT THAT WILL TAKE THE
CURRENTLY EXISTING BIT
PREFERENCE FROM FIVE TO TEN
PERCENT PER STATE.
SAYS RELATED TO CALIFORNIA
GROWN.
A CALIFORNIA PACKED AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS OVER. THOSE PRODUCED AT
A STATE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THE BILL.
SECOND OKAY.
ALRIGHT.
OKAY WHAT WHEN THERE HAS BEEN NO
ALLOCATION OF THE FIVE PERCENT
WHY IS THAT.
BELIEVE THAT WE ALREADY NEED TEN
PERCENT.
SO DURING THE BREAK WE MET WITH
A.
NUMBER OF LOCAL FARMERS IN OUR
DISTRICT IMPERIAL AND.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WHICH IS A VERY
HIGH PRODUCTION.
AREA FOR THE STATE AND IT
BECAME.
QUITE CLEAR THAT.
ALTHOUGH THEY WERE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE FIVE
PERCENT.
THE COMPETITIVENESS OF THAT
EXISTS.
WITH OUR NEIGHBORS TO THE SOUTH
AND PERHAPS EVEN STATES TO
THE EASTERN ARIZONA BEING ONE OF
THEM.
pCOULD BE DONE TO ASSIST
ODD THE AG INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
JUST YESTERDAY THERE WAS AN
ARTICLE WRITTEN IN THE LOCAL
PAPER THAT YOUR SON THAT TALKED
ABOUT THE NEED.
FOR US TO CONTINUE TO ELEVATE.
YOU KNOW THE CONSCIOUSNESS OF
BUYING CALIFORNIA PRODUCE
I'M HELPING YOU KNOW THE
INDUSTRY REALLY. MEAN ALL OF THE
OTHER EXTERNAL FORCES THAT THAT
MAKE IT VERY VERY DIFFICULT.
FOR THEM AYE TO COMPETE.
ONE EXAMPLE THOSE BROUGHT TO
OUR ATTENTION.
I JUST MET ARTICLE BUT SOME OF
OUR LOCAL FARMERS IS OUR
PROXIMITY TO THE MEXICAN BORDER.
MAKES IT VERY VERY COMPETITIVE.
FOR FARMERS IN IMPAIR COUNTY.
TO DO BUSINESS.
A RELATIVELY SPEAKING TO THOSE
DOING BUSINESS.
IN MEXICO LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
CAPITAL OF BAJA CALIFORNIA SO.
ALTHOUGH OF FIVE PERCENT WAS A
GOOD GOAL THAT THAT WAS A CHEAP
LAST YEAR. IN OUR IMMEDIATE
CONVERSATION SOON AFTER AT IT
WAS THOUGHT THAT THE TEN PERCENT
COULD PROBABLY BE.
I THAT MUCH MORE HELPFUL.
LONG ANSWER BUT THAT THAT'S.
IT'S MY ERA.
THANK YOU FEEDBACK.
YOU CAN SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
NOTHING CHAIRWOMAN AT JIM
HOUSTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION AYE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE OF SIX
AND JUST A POINT PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE YEAH THIS EIGHTEEN
YEARS AGO SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO
THAT I WAS A STAFF PERSON AND
SOMEONE SALINAS IS OFFICE.
WHEN WE FIRST RAN A CALIFORNIA
GROOM BILL AND AND SO IT WAS
VERY GRATIFYING TO SEE IT
SEVENTEEN YEARS LATER. I FINALLY
GET A SIGNED INTO LAW AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT TO THINK ABOUT
IS YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS HERE IN THE IN
THE NATION IN THE WORLD FOR CA
FOR CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE. AND
I THINK ONE THING THAT GETS LOST
IN THAT IS THAT WHEN A FARMER OR
A PROCESSING PLANT HAS TO FILE
THE PAPERWORK WITH THE VARIOUS
REGULATORY AGENCIES COUNTIES I'M
AT SACRAMENTO. THAT'S MONEY
THAT'S TAKEN OUT OF THAT CAN
UNIT IS ECONOMY.
ALRIGHT THAT'S TO MY THIS TAKEN
OUT OF FRESNO OR A ROW SEE OR
LINDSAY OR I'M IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE THE IMPERIAL VALLEY AND
GOES UP TO SACRAMENTO AND THERE
MAY BE. I'M NO GOOD REASON FOR
THAT BUT THAT'S MONEY THAT DOES
NOT GO BACK INTO INVESTMENT THAT
THAT'S NOT GO BACK INTO WAGES
ETCETERA AND SO THAT CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE A HISTORY OF
SUPPORTING.
SORT OF VALUE DRIVEN.
PURCHASES INNER IN ENERGY FIELD
FOR INSTANCE WOULD MANDATE THE
PURCHASE OF ELECTRICAL FLEETS
I'M IN OUR ENERGY PURCHASES. AND
A AND A RATE PAYERS  PAY PAY
HIGHER PORTION TEST TO MEET
ENERGY GOALS WHICH WE SUPPORT.
AND BUT AND WE HAVE NOT DONE
THAT IN THE REALM OF OF
CALIFORNIA ACT AND SO AND IT WAS
VERY NICE TO SEE THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION TO FIVE
PERCENT BUT MR GARCIA'S POINT.
I'M YOU KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT THE
MARGINS OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
COST OF PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA
AND I GET COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES AND OTHER COUNTRIES FIVE
PERCENT IS IS A DROP IN THE
BUCKET SAP. AND TEN PERCENT IS
IS SIGNIFICANTLY WE REALLY
APPRECIATE AYE THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS EFFORTS OF
LEADERSHIP ON THIS THANK YOU.
REAL SPEAKING SUPPORT TODAY.
YOU MAY SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
AND THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
BUT.
NICE TO SEE YOU MISTER HUSSEIN
I'M A AND AND I I WAS LIKE YEAH
I I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT
WE JUST DID FIVE AND AND NOW
WE'RE DOING TEN AND YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES WE DO THINGS THAT ARE
ASPIRATIONAL TO. I'D MISTER
MISTER HOUSTON IS THIS.
SWITCHING TO A DIFFERENT TEAM
NOW SO HE KNOWS THAT THAT A
SOMETIMES THE THE GOVERNOR MAY
NOT SIGN A BUT I THINK THE
MESSAGE CONTINUES TO BE CLEAR TO
OUR FARMERS TO OUR AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITY TO EVERYBODY ELSE.
THAT THIS THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT OUR OUR OUR VALUES RESULT
IN POLICIES THAT SOMETIMES DON'T
PUT OUR OUR STATE ECONOMY AT THE
BEST ADVANTAGE AND SO I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS WE
VALUE.
WE'VE AYE WORKERS RIGHTS WE
VALUE THE ENVIRONMENT WE ALSO
NEED TO BE ABLE TO VALUE PUT
VALUE ON THAT PRODUCE IT IS
PRODUCED AT SOMETIMES A HIGHER
COST THAN CAN BE ACHIEVED IN
ARIZONA SAY. OR MEXICO SO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
CHRISTIAN I WILL LE LET ME START
BY SAYING I THINK YOU TO YOUR
STAFF AND I SHOULD HAVE SAID
THAT IN MY OPENING THEY DID AN
EXCELLENT JOB WITH THE ANALYSIS.
MENTIONED DATA.
YOU KNOW IT'S PUTTING OUR OUR.
MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS.
BUT AND TERMS OF US STANDING BY.
WHAT IS AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
JOBS ECONOMIC ENGINE DRIVER FOR
US HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO? THANK
YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR APPLE.
THINK YOU VERY MUCH SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE THEN A MONTH EGGMAN
PIE TIME A MONTH AS A MAN I
PATTERSON.
BURKE.
SAID A MONTH THIS.
THAT A MONTH IF I LACKEY. LACKEY
AYE MEDINA. MEDINA AYE QUIRK
SILVA.
SILVA AYE.
BILLS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
US I WOULD INTERCHANGEABLE
SHOULDN'T.
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECOND I'M BILL HAS BEEN THAT
NOT AS IN MOTION AND SECOND OF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
CONSENT.
CONSENT IS AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
EIGHT OBERNOLTE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS TH
OF THE MONTH IS EIGHT MEN BY.
THE MOMENTOUS EGGMAN AYE
PATTERSON.
BURKE.
SAID A MONTH THIS.
SAID MONTH THIS AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
QUIRK SILVA.
SILVA AYE.
VERY MUCH.
.
BIG
BUDGET IS UP BUT THAT STEP THAT.
THE.
PROCEED.
I THINK.
WE AREA THERE ARE FIRE APPEAR
TODAY.
.
I AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY THREE BUT AND THIS BILL
COMES AS A RESULT OF IT AUDIT WE
DID WE DIDN'T AUDIT LAST YEAR ON
THE CALIFORNIA WATER FIX
SOMETHING THAT COULD LIKE HOW
MUCH IS GOING TO COST WORDS
GOING ON WITH THIS.
NO ONE IS THINGS THAT WE
DISCOVERED WAS.
COST ACOSTA PROJECTS CAN
OVERRUN. AND SO AS I THINK WE'RE
ENTERING A PERIOD OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE ARE REALLY WORKING ON
TRYING THING UP INFRASTRUCTURE
HOW DO WE BUILD WHAT WE DO. THIS
BILL SIMPLY SAYS THAT IF AN
AGENCY OF STATE AGENCY A BIT
SOMETHING OVER HUNTER HAS A
CONTRACT OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS PROJECT THEY'RE WORKING
ON IF THAT RUNS OVER. THAT THAT
AND THEN NEEDS TO BE POSTED ON
THE WEBSITE SO THAT WE CAN ALL
SEE IT RUN OVER AND BY HOW MUCH
RUN OVER AND WHY IT'S RUN OVER.
SO AGAIN AS WE AS MR LACKEY
SAID WHEN PEOPLE ARE WATCHING AS
WE TEND TO BEHAVE BETTER
SOMETIMES THESE THINGS HAPPEN
PROJECTS RUN OVER WHAT WE THINK
THEY'RE GONNA ABOUT GO OVER. BUT
WE'VE SEEN WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL FOR INSTANCE
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT. EVERYONE
AGREES ON A PRICE TAG THAT GOES
UP AND UP AND PEOPLE ARE CURIOUS
ABOUT THAT BUT WHY IS THAT
HAPPENING. SO THIS WOULD TO SAY
THEY WOULD SIMPLY HAVE TO POST
THAT IT'S GONE OVER HOW MUCH
IT'S GOING OVER AND PROVIDE SOME
OF THOSE TIMELINES.
BUT THIS DOES NOT APPLY TO LOCAL
AGENCIES ANOTHER WITH SOME LATE
OPPOSITION THAT CAME FROM SOME
LOCAL AGENCIES DOES NOT APPLY TO
THEM IT ONLY APPLIES TO STATE
AGENCIES I'M PROJECTS GOING
FORWARD.
A.
TO LEARN.
YOU HAVE ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE
IT TESTIFIED SPORT.
BOB.
IN A SECOND.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MA'AM I WOULD JUST ASK YOU
FOR YOUR. SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THAT AGAIN I THINK PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT PROVIDES
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVIDES OUR
CITIZENS A WAITER THAT THEY CAN
CHECK UP ON WHAT WE'RE DOING.
VERY GOOD.
TRAFFIC ALREADY FEDERAL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT A MONTH THIS EGGMAN BY A
MONTH AS EGGMAN AYE PATTERSON.
BURKE.
THAT AMOUNT THIS SAID ABOUT THIS
AYE LACKEY AYE AYE LACKEY AYE
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN UP FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER ROGERS OF YOU'D
LIKE TO SIGN ON TO A SOME OF THE
BILLS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DONE.
FOR A BEAT TWENTY ONE FIFTY
SEVEN THAT THE DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SAID A MONTH
THAT'S.
SAID ABOUT THIS I.
AB TWENTY TO FIFTY TWO LEE MON
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SAID ABOUT THIS. SAID ABOUT THIS
I.
AND THAT'S A WRAP